hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and as you can tell by the title
the moveset four are a mushi and the
shaman were displayed on reddit today if
you want to call it leaked you can go
for it
splice did put this on reddit he did get
approval by Ubisoft and he did send me
the link to these so huge shout out to
him for sending me these but either way
we're gonna go through the move set kind
of talk about it real quick see what
we're looking at here but our moosh is
up first so let's get right into that so
in the first image on the hero specific
side we have the classic renowned and
revenge mode just like every other
character and we have the chain
finishers during your chains for extra
damage after a top stands attack use the
heavy attack in top stance and then
after a side stance attack use heavy and
any side stance for a chain finisher
obviously this is PC some of you guys on
console don't know really what these are
that right mouse button is going to be
heavy let left mouse button is going to
be light attack the middle mouse button
is guard break and then they see on the
right side that you see is full guard
stance we'll get into what some of those
are real quick cuz I know not everybody
plays PC I don't either I had to look up
these controls while I'm doing this
video so it might be a little bit
awkward and I do have to apologize
this is 100% unscripted I do not write a
script for this I didn't really have the
time to I don't have the time to write
this script at the moment so we're gonna
go right off my head so I do apologize
if this is very very bad but either way
continuing on though we have the swift
reprisal frizzle your twin Vipers and
rushing wind are considered a chain
starter now I do see rushing wind on the
far right but I do not know what twin
Vipers are maybe that's another list
down the line we'll have to look at that
when we get to it
moving on to the move list we can see
that he has to change finishers a to
chains which is a temp a tempest and
then tempest alternate now it is an
infinite chain as shown by the infinity
symbol and this might be a little bit
confusing but on the analog right there
where the direction where it has the
full Mouse and it's lit up white with an
arrow that is the direction you want to
be pointed in I'm assuming that is the
guard stance you want to be in so to
start it you do you have to be it you
have to do a top light or a top heavy
and then follow that up with either a
left guard stance or right stance
whether that be a light or a heavy that
is the tempest and you could probably
just go back and forth so you could do
like top heavy side heavy top light side
and just keep mixing and matching and
all that good stuff and then the next
two attacks once again we have the
rushing wind and then the rusher wing
alternate and then this is going to be a
forward dash so if you are on the a if
you are on Xbox or ps4 you're just gonna
move your analog stick up with the
spacebar being a so you're just gonna
dash forward once again that and then
you're going to do a top-heavy this
might be it's kind of similar to a roach
YZ kind of thing where he does like
little back step to the I don't know
what these damn moves are called
weirdoes a little back step and then
slices them in any direction once again
it's a back step or a forward step to a
heavy attack on the top and that is the
rushing wind the Russian when alternate
is very similar to the rushing wind
except it's going to be a heavy attack
in the side guard stance instead of the
top guard stance next up we have blade
blockable which is going to be the c key
which is the defensive stance similar to
warlord conquer all those guys would
shield the stuff like that you know what
I mean but he is also going to have a
full guard stance as well just with the
C key like normal ring the bell and fury
Unleashed are going to be the next moves
and the last one for this page there is
still another page full of stuff but
we'll get to that in a bit
but for this it is going to be full
block stance and then after a block from
any direction you can follow up with the
light attack for the ring of the bell
which is an unblockable light or a heavy
attack in the top guard stands for the
fury Unleashed moving on to the next
page we now have the once again the here
a specific stuff and this is going to be
the deadly feint you can now cancel your
heavy finisher and twin Vipers by doing
a light attack in any other direction
and then special moves cancel you can
cancel your twin Vipers your zone attack
and your rushing wind by pressing the e
key now the e key is probably similar to
the B button as for Xbox and PC and all
those different controls but it's
probably meaning the faint button
befuddle which is pressing heavy attack
after a missed sprint attack to follow
up with any heavy attack shortly after
it's probably similar to the bamboozle
of gladiator except this does damage
instead of just dazed as your opponent
on the side we have the next we have the
last three things which is going to be
twin Vipers which is in the heavy block
stance a you do the defensive block just
like the normal fury unleashed but
instead of doing a top heavy you do a
side heavy after it to get the
unblockable heavy twin Vipers what you
can also do is instead of doing a move
you can click the
middle-mouse button which for on Xbox
and ps4 is are is the guard break button
and then you can do a kick sim probably
similar to shinobi's maybe a little bit
more but once again it's going to be a
unblockable kick and then like always he
does have a sprinting attack with the
heavy button but not many people do use
that but it's still a move and that was
the shaman move set from what I can tell
he doesn't have too many unblockable as
most of us from the top or from the
guard stance or from the full block
stance it doesn't really seem that
useful because obviously if you're in
full block stance people can just guard
break out of it or you could just get
guard broken out of it and you can't
counter Givi out of it so that might be
a bit of a problem I have no clue how
this character is going to stack up so
who knows either way we're gonna move to
the shaman move set and there is a lot
of stuff we need to talk about for this
so for the shaman move set the hero
specific stuff like normal is the
renowned and revenge mode and on this
page it says defense is reflex since she
is an assassin she obviously has the
reflex guard which her guard stances
remains only active for a limited amount
of time for the moves her chain attacks
are Blood omen bone omen and by omen
which are light light heavy light heavy
and heavy heavy in that order and then
we have two unblockable z' which are
predators hunger and predators and mercy
predators hunger is move forward or back
with a with the spacebar which is
obviously the dodge to either do a dash
forward or a dash back and hold the
guard break button that is going to be
the middle mouse button for PC obviously
that's just X for us console players or
square-free on ps4 all that good stuff
but it's going to be it looks like an
unblockable guard rake maybe there might
be a move in there who knows but on
predators mercy is a little bit
different it's the same exact thing but
if the character is in blood trance then
there's a different type of move we
haven't seen what blood trance is yet
maybe it's further down the line but one
that comes up we'll talk about that and
then next up is Raven's claw which is a
bleed attack which is after any chain
like blood omen bone omen and by omen
which are the three at the top you can
do any attack that is a light or a heavy
in the left guard stance right guard
stance or top guard stance and then
follow that up with a light attack to
complete the bleed damage of Raven's
claw on the second page we now have the
mountain lions power which is finish any
chain with a left heavy attack for an
unblockable attack so obviously going
back to the three chains we talked about
you can end those with a left
before an unblockable portion the good
blood omen is good blood omen starts
with two light attacks if you hit the
first light attack perform the second
light in the same stance to make the
strike faster throw short cuts is throw
can shortcut into Wildcats rage with a
heavy attack in throw can shortcut and
the Predators hunger with a guard break
and blood transfer out can shortcut to
predators mercy with guard break now
this seems like there's going to be a
lot of moves a lot of combos involved
kind of maybe a little bit similar to
Highlander where you can kick you know
feint the kick and go for the grab to
bait out that bat that - back grab the
grab the person throw him down for that
unblockable heavy it seems like that
what's what it might be I'm not entirely
sure but there is going to be lots of
moves and complicated move sets with
this character and then the last one is
the zone attack cancel and can be
cancelled with the e key or B if you're
on counsel or circle if you're on ps4 or
should say after the second strike and
can be canceled into ravens Biol after
the second strike now for the moves we
have Ravens bio which is very similar to
Raven's claw except Ravens bios use
during a heavy opener and his own attack
as opposed to Raven claw which is in a
chain the exact same thing it just
depends on the situation you're in
Ravens beak is after a deflect you can
go for a light attack for a bleed
unblockable wildcat swiftness is the
next thing which is going to be the a or
d key + space which for the console
players is just a dash to the left or
right using the a or X whatever console
you happen to be on and then using a
heavy attack so similar to a Roachy
where he does the side the side light
you know with the dash light this time
it's going to be a dash with a heavy
attack while the cat's rage is going to
be a forward or backward edge - and then
in left top or right guard stance hold
the heavy attack and then that will
trigger the wildcat rage move and then
obviously she also has her not in guard
mode which is the classical sprinting
and then just holding heavy for the
Wildcats pounce for the last picture it
seems like we have a basically a lot of
hero specific stuff and this is blood
transfer point is bleeding shaman enters
blood trance blood transyl it's the
shaman heal on every strike now this
one's crazy because if we do go back
there's a couple things that you can do
in blood stance like the Predators mercy
we showed I've talked about in the first
image if you are reading along with me
and you can do a lot of other things in
blood
as well so this is going to be crazy and
the fact that she even heels on every
strike that she deals when the opponent
is bleeding so you definitely do not
want to be bleeding on her or when
you're with her now I do assume that
this might be a little bit overpowered
so she probably has a lot a lot of low
health may be similar to shinobi to keep
the balance but regardless this is
really crazy not only that but predators
mercy and blood trends predators mercy
replaces predators hunger predators
mercy uses the same controls as
predators hunger but now does damage to
the opponent as to where it didn't
before predator mercy also has a second
chance a missed predators mercy attack
can be linked into a Wildcats rage which
is the dashed forward or backward with a
heavy in any direction and then
withholding of the heavy button or into
another's predator mercy with a guard
break so once again tons of moves tons
of mix-ups you can do and then the
bottom on the left side of this page
while running predators hunger and
predators mercy can be canceled into
Wildcats wager rage with the hold of the
heavy attack and Wildcats rage can be
canceled into predators hunger and
predators mercy with the hold of the
guard break so once again wildcats rage
and a lot of predator hunger and mercy
moves can be coexisting and you know a
bunch of swapping and stuff like that so
once again tons of mix-ups and even to
add to the mix up she can even cancel
predators hunger mercy and wildcats
raids with the b button or obviously
just the faint button so once again just
tons of things you can do with her for
the chain starters Wildcat swiftness can
be initiated into vile omen replacing
the opener wildcats rage can be
initiated into vile omen replacing the
opener and wildcats pounce can be
initiated into bio omen replacing the
opener now for bio omen is a just
standard heavy heavy so you can do any
of those three moves and then follow up
with a heavy attack to do that chain
instead and then the last two we have
guard break cancel and dodge cancel
heavy attacks can be canceled into a
guard break simply by pressing the X
button as opposed to just pressing the B
button for the feint and then going for
the guard break so it's more of a soft
fame and the dodged cancel heavy
finisher can be canceled with dodge just
by pressing a so overall she has tons of
mix-ups
and she has decent bleed damage and a
couple unblockable x' that she can use
to her mixup kit and stuff
like that so as who opposed of what I'm
looking at just from the moveset shaman
looks like the better choice now
that might not be how it is in the
gameplay I have yet to see any gameplay
because obviously the people that got
early access do not have the rights to
post anything until tomorrow but either
way the the I will have to wait for the
gameplay to determine who I'm gonna use
but honestly going by these movesets
shaman looks the best choice she has
tons of mix-ups that are probably gonna
be a little bit difficult to learn but
when mastered you're an absolute force
on that battlefield that's going to be
the end of the video today guys judging
off the move said tell me I want you
guys tell me in the comments below which
one which character you're gonna be
meaning did your opinion stay the same
are you gonna do the same character or
are you gonna main the different one
based off the move set that I've showed
you now I just want to say a quick thank
you once again to spliced for sending me
this and obviously getting the approval
to send this stuff in the first place
and put it on reddit but thank you for
sending that to me directly splice
really do appreciate that anyway guys
I'll leave his channel in the
description once again with with the two
links to the reddit post as you were
following along or if you want to look
them over again that's completely fine
but anyway you guys liked the video if
you did enjoy subscribe if you're new
once again we cover the leaks we cover
the news we cover the discussion
regarding for honor and we cover all
that good stuff and my two most recent
videos are popping up on screen we have
two dev streams that are that we talked
about all with the season 4 info and
just in case you haven't been filled in
yet so you can be caught up and be
caught in the loop with everybody else
and with that guys I hope you have a
great rest of your weekend and peace out
guys see you